Perfect specimen, right here baby. Never made a damn mistake in my life.
✞ Christian Channel ✞
Women respecter
I'm god damn perfect...
I can't, I can't joke too much in this video
You may have heard about that what happened with Harvey Weinstein Weinstein
famous Hollywood producer
now facing sexual assault claims, sexual abuse claims, and rape...
claims.
A bad person Harvey Weinstein is a bad person sort of putting up this feminist front
You know supporting all these charities
When really he's a piece of shit
a lot of celebrities were shocked about hearing this news a lot of them went out to
publicly condemned
Harvey rightfully
so we have Ben Affleck for example saying I am saddened and
Angry that a man who I worked with used his position of power
to intimidate, sexually harass and
manipulate many women over decades
Thank you
Ben Affleck from one women respecter to to another thank you Ben Affleck for being a good person and
standing up against these horrible despicable acts oh, oh
Damn it
Damn it Ben Ben Affleck asks reporter to get them titties out literally the day after Ben tweets I acted inappropriately
Towards, Miss Burton, and I sincerely
apologize I agree
Life
Comes at you
fast
It just swims by sometimes one day. You're a women respecter, the other day a women disrespecter
I don't even know where I'm standing anymore
life comes at you fast. I was even personally involved in a similar sort of
Twisted turn of events lately I noticed a tweet from Andy signor
He was quoting me after the Wall Street Journal event I said I'm in no way supporting any kind of hateful attitudes
But you are Pewdiepie YouTube commentators are rotten enough without you
encouraging them
Those damn YouTube commenters, and they're rotten, they're rotten enough Felix. Thank you.
Oh, honest trailer creator Andy Signor accused of sexual abuse oh
No, how did this happen why do all these people?
That publicly say they're against something
Do that very same thing oh, it's so weird it's almost like it's really easy
To say that you are a good person
Instead of acting like a good person Wow who would have thought
this way easier to just tweet
I respect wahmen, but but behind closed doors is a whole nother story now sexual abuse sexual aside serious things
I'm not trying to make fun of it or making light of it, but it is a sort of interesting phenomenon
I literally have a dozen example of other
Guys doing this very same thing portraying this feminist front
But you know it came out
With sexual assault, there's been so many examples. I'll leave a link to it. I don't want to stir up this whole thing
these people
publicly condemning these things, and I'm obviously not everyone is guilty of this but
They do it because they're afraid of being exposed themselves so they try and distance themself as far as possible from it
But it's also
extremely hypocritical and
Personally I hate this I hate this sort of idea that
You think you're a better than someone basically because your phrasing it in a sentence
you know I am good and
You are bad because I would never do what you did. I am perfect. Okay you were terrible
I think I think the firewatch guy is a
Prime example of this vanna none
He tweeted about
Me saying the n-word and I think that's and I honestly I think that's fine if you want to publicly create
I deserve to be criticized for it the way he acted on trying to shut down my video
Trying to ruin my career. That's sort of when it becomes a problem
Instead of trying to communicate and discuss when these things occur
it it often more often than not it just seems to be a train of shame and
harassment and attacking
When really it solves nothing
To do that all you're doing is putting yourself on a pedestal it has become so important how
people publicly perceive you that people will act against what I think they think is the right thing to do
Because like I said
It's more important that people see you in a good line it sort of puts morals over logic
Which is a sort of becomes like a paradox because what you think you're doing that is immoral?
Becomes immoral
Am I making any sense here?
I just see a lot of intelligent people on Twitter that act like batshit crazy people
Because they want to be perceived as good people and I think this all stems from
Self-worth especially with social media people it's such an ocean of people how can I stand out?
How can people know that I'm important it's sort of like
It's a small example, but people putting literally what their diet is in their Twitter bio
Yeah, I'm the I'm big like
Congratulations, and I think this sort of self-worth has created such a divide in specially the generation above me. It's almost like a social
Religion that unless you think and act in this very specific frame of mind, then we will shut you out
and we will publicly shame you and
and uhh,
You're not allowed in our social group anymore
but literally all this does is having people like Ben and
Andy and so many others to make this sort of posts
Because they're afraid they are scared of being outed. They're scared of being an outcast
And they're scared of being associated with the bad crowd I think with my generation
It's completely different and younger
No one cares context matter more
And I'm glad this is the sort of way of thinking that will be going forward in the future
And it's I think it's the reason why I'm even able to keep making youtube videos
I'm sure I've been I would have been stripped away from from it if that wasn't the case
Because the majority of people on YouTube and the majority of people watching look
Doesn't look at it in this frame of mind, and I do think it's important for the future
I do think it's important for the sake of freedom of speech
Which seems to be such a blurred line of definition these days?
I think if you want a person to be punished and afraid of saying certain things
Then you have the freedom of speech of doing so
But you are also
Bad for doing so don't act like these people that I mentioned in this video and pretend that you are somehow a better person online
because who knows.
Life comes at you fast.